well good evening Orlando welcome to
Piers Morgan and sensored I was going to
start tonight's show with a little
monologue about Prince Harry whining
again being called again moaning about
security again the usual stuff it's not
uninteresting he lost a big case today
uh and his ongoing battle with the
British government over his right to
have
proper Royal protection whenever he's in
United Kingdom and he wants us the
British taxpayer to pay for him or if
that's not the case he wants the right
to pay for it himself well that right
today has been rejected and we're going
to come to that debate in a moment but
can't get out of my head something I
watched earlier I just can't I'm trying
to but it's lurking in my membranes
like a large lizard
because I can't quite believe what I
heard this is Ed Davis he's a knight of
the realm in the United Kingdom he's had
the tap on the shoulder from whoever it
was the queen or William or Charles or
somebody
for his services to this country because
it's supposedly an intelligent man and
yet on this morning with Nick Ferrari on
LBC Radio he was asked that whole
question
what's a woman what do they look like
and this is what he said
think about it and debate it with a bit
more maturity and a bit more compassion
well that's what secure Starman once
said to me and he never did answer the
question can a woman have a penis
well I've just answered that question
they can
um listen I've made it really clear that
if people
um uh the vast majority people will have
the same gender as their biological sex
but a small number one so a woman can
have a penis well quite clearly
what
sorry
what do you mean quite clearly
what are you talking about
quite clearly women can have penises
what are you talking about you are the
leader of a major national political
party in this country
you've already seen the first Minister
Scotland lose her job for being unable
to defend women's rights for thinking
it's fine for a male rapist to be put in
a women's prison she had to go we've
seen secure stama wriggling around I
mean let's watch a bit of kirst armor
trying to explain what a woman is
for 99. I don't know nine percent of
women everything is a matter of biology
for
99.9 something percent of women
um it's all biological and it's very
straightforward and let me be clear for
the for the vast majority of women this
is all about biology and of course they
don't have a penis we all know that I
don't think we can conduct this
debate with
you know sorry no no no it's just no no
I just
a woman can't have a penis I don't think
that
um discussing this issue in this way
helps
that's Shakir starmer another Knight of
the realm
knighted because he's a smart lawyer
intelligent man
also failing to explain
simply what a woman is which of course
is just an adult human female it's not a
trick question this ever used to be a
controversial thing
and yet he can't answer
and now sir Ed Davey has taken it to a
new level altogether
let's just replay what Ed Davis said
again just to really try and comprehend
exactly what he's saying
I think we need to manage this and think
about it and debate it with a bit more
maturity and a bit more compassion well
that's what sakir Starman once said to
me and he never did answer the question
can a woman have a penis
well I've just answered that question
they can
um listen I've made it really clear that
if people
um uh the vast majority people will have
the same gender as their biological sex
but a small number one so a woman can
have a penis well quite clearly
it's unbelievable isn't it isn't it
or have I gone mad
unbelievable that in 2023
this is now something that political
leaders are saying that women can have
penises
they can't
it's a biological fact it's not
transphobic it's not about trans rights
I absolutely believe that trans people
should have rights to fairness and
equality like everybody else in life
regardless of any anything else
but you cannot deny biological
scientific fact and when two of the
three major political parties in this
country are run by men who are denying
biological fact with these public
statements
what does that say to women in this
country
who's defending their rights
who is explaining what a woman is who's
standing up for women
who is just telling the country what a
woman is it's unbelievable anyway rant
over
but I have had that clip in my head all
day and I can't get out of my head
thank God Rishi soon at the Prime
Minister when I asked him that question
at number 10 down the street just simply
reply it's an adult human female that's
all that needs to be said like a man is
an adult human male and trans people are
trans people
and everyone should get respected but
you can't deny biological fact
right
it's got that off my chest
um